eyes mark walberg he's starring in the
movie mild 22 hits theaters this Friday
and he joins us from New York City how
are you mark what time did you get up
today alright and then you were throwing
some steel around I was in the gym baby
I'm getting after it
who was with somebody spotting you no no
I'm not lifting heavy everything is
functional movement all of you add let
ik and mobile as possible
have you changed as a workup on the wine
all the Valentine's Day until July have
you adopted the Tom Brady method no well
because I still feel like I'm going
across the middle and I might get hit by
Jin kam chancellor so I can't be just
working out with a couple beds I got to
do some real strength and conditioning
how do I get the four am club you just
come with us baby
yeah with us you're what I bought what
do I have to wear and do I have to look
a certain way no I would say the only
thing no spandex and no speedo have you
crossed paths with LeBron in LA I
haven't yet but I'm happy that he's in
LA I am happy to this I am happy that
the Celtics has a clear path for the
Eastern Conference Finals and enter the
championship who is a better chance of
winning a championship this year the
Celtics Red Sox or Patriot actually the
Red Sox Patriots and the public's all
have a chance no no chance o best chance
I would have to say right now you have
to say the Red Sox got the best record
in baseball they are 10/10 game leads on
the Yankee and you know we got JD
Martinez and Mookie Betts we're looking
good do you do you have cheap food I
don't have cheap food right now I think
when I get to where I want to be I
designed eat
cheat a little bit but you know what I
mean all the way in or I'm all the way
out there's no kind of you know
go-between start over you know sneak
better that tougher to put on weight or
take off wait for a movie ah
it's obviously easier at my age to put
on weight you know the metabolism slows
down so yeah much much easier to put all
the way but in this movie mile 22 so
you're CIA operative you have to look a
certain way right yes oh no I see you
know a lot of times people sending me
Steve Antin speeches to kind of look at
a character inspiration
oddly enough so he just wanted Pete just
wanted me to be ripped and lonesome
Erica I was kind of heavy because I was
coming here from pain & gain Deepwater
Horizon I was eating he wanted me to be
as heavy as possible and I was shaping
an oil rig worker eating fried food
Louisiana and then Patriots day you know
the nagas shaped off with a bad leg so
he was like you know what forget yeah
because I after that I got into really
good shape he was like I never get the
rim or foam but I wanted a powerful work
so I spent five months training and as
soon as we got on into the same city
every night he was trying to take me out
to eat and drink and I just had to
refuse mile 22 hits theaters coming up
this Friday but when you look what's the
most amazing transformation you've ever
seen with an actor you know you look at
De Niro in Raging Bull from you know
when he was in fighting shape to working
with Jake LaMotta you know kind of doing
dinner theater you know Christian Bale
and The Machinist
you know I'm from 212 to 137 but you
know I think it's much the physical
preparation is just you know a
requirement but also the letter
preparation so you've seen many people
do many amazing before you know you have
a Dallas buyers club with Matthew
McConaughey
what's the belly like what movie have
you stopped if you're going through the
channels you that you stopped at yours
and you actually watch it a little while
lone survivor
anytime invincible a little bit because
I love I love the football you know the
true stories obviously are the things
that I find the most compelling but I
actually saw some clips from The Gambler
that we do this kind of little
retrospect on my career which look
really cool but yeah I would say
probably though a survivor if you got
into the Octagon with Ronda Rousey who
plays Sam snow in mile 22 how would you
fare right now I'm good to go but you
know that's my girl I would only have
her back I would never try to to fight
how did you think what did you think of
her acting ability you know what
everybody expects her to do lots of
great kick-ass action which she is more
than capable but it's her dramatic
performance it's one of the real
standouts in the film she did an amazing
job
she's got her head on her shoulders the
right way she really focused on kind of
doing it one performance at the time
slowly building a real career and a body
of work that will allow her to continue
to grow
you know from movie to movie what you
think of the Oscar is adding the new
popular film category cool whatever they
want to do here or there it's all good I
think you know many up many many popular
films have one in the past I think
recently a lot of independent movies
that you know mass audiences haven't
seen have gotten you know no more
accolades good I I saw where you were
tweeting out about Baker Mayfield is
this a man-crush does Brady know that
you have a man crush on Baker Mayfield
you know Baker Baker is a friend you
know really happy was excited to see him
go number one but I think I think
Cleveland Queen there was a couple of
plays away last year from winning you
know four or five games I bet I bet on
them to win five and a half or more and
I think you know I would be surprised to
be on a winning record I like Baker a
lot I like Jared golf a lot Brady
obviously is a great is the greatest of
all time I mean if he's not secure and
that's bad
during an eight and nothing well then
nothing will make and secure but Grady
the greatest of all time but you know I
think Baker he's just a special kid
really nice and you know considering
kind was spent on a third party Medicare
he's Mark Wahlberg the movie is mild
twenty-two which hits theaters this
Friday in the distance of twenty two
miles from the American Embassy in
Southeast Asia to an airfield
for extraction there a lot of violence
in this trailer so far that I've seen
mark two driven action movie but once we
step on the gas we never let up and
again remember Baker Mayfield is not in
the same division I would never refer
just for the back never Dolphins
quarterback or Bills quarterback so
that's also you know make that clear
wait so you're not rooting for Sam
Darnell to do well you know I would I
hope he does well on the jet you can I
don't wanna I don't want to wish anybody
bad I just don't you know I think the
Patriots have a lot more winning to do
soccer team are you trying to bring a
soccer team keep a soccer team in
Columbus are you we have a car
dealership in Columbus and I was just
happen yesterday if I would do anything
to keep the team and I said I would look
into it I would actually I have to ask
mr. Kraft about the state of the MLS and
if it was it would be a smart investment
but I certainly love being Columbus I
love being part of that community and
you know it was something that I didn't
know about it wasn't aware of until
somebody asked me yesterday
are you soccer fan I like yes I am you
know what I was kind of I was pushing
back like a lot of American sports fans
and Soccer World Cup actually really
brought me in I had always watched and
loved the u.s. women's team and all that
they were able to accomplish that as a
dad of two girls what what inspiration
they were bringing to so many young
girls all over the country and all over
the world but uh the World Cup I was
nine out of ten picks and the only time
I lost was when I picked with my heart
and I picked England to win to go to the
final against France
that's because I buy I'm friendly with
with cane and Lela wait you're you're
friends with Harry Caine Harry I my
brother Paul and I visited the Tottenham
Hotspurs and we were talking about doing
some stuff we played we played a little
soccer we're on the pitch with lardelli
and I hired those guys came by the
static transformers we got to spend some
time together yes and the home fans are
those guys
how many Wahlburgers much did you know
my arsenal friends all hater I have a
lot of friends singing but we have 27
locations open they'll welcome another
10 before the end of 2018 and then we
have a big big expansion plan for 2019
man look at you
you're gonna get out of acting one day
and then just become like this
business tycoon well I hope to just
because I kind of pick and choose where
I want to work with a little walk and
not not at this pace but you know it's
been great because the movies that have
been really passionate about making I
think that I've been developing and
creating on my own are all starting to
come together and we're getting them all
made so but no I'd like to slow down be
more behind the scenes but hopefully you
know we kind of own a controller and
content in the future as well how would
your oldest now about to be 15 well we
saw a little bit of it what was that a
year and a half ago when I was I was
world why has it gotten better worse you
know what every once in a while I got a
love you you're the best but mostly
design is like everything in hey she but
she thought she's in New York right now
I give her a little bit more freedom a
little bit more chance having breakfast
with a friend and then supposed to go to
two stores I've got people you know
within 30 feet okay I couldn't believe
she was up because you know she was up
at 7:00 this morning and then she goes I
never slept that like oh my god I said
we can't go with your friends you get
eight hours asleep
to go sleep tomorrow very well while
anybody boys come around yet yeah a
couple here there but they seem nice and
polite you know they can come over to
the house and you know hang around in my
presence go for swim and you know about
this far to go do you put on a tank top
and do a party pump before they come
over just to remind them I don't go that
far but I'm sitting right there in the
Cabana I got full view very respectful
you know what it's inevitable so I mean
I don't know I went from you know keep
her locked up till 3:30 to maybe a mare
up at 19 I don't know what to do every
day changing the approach to the
philosophy I think you got you got it I
hate to say this as the daughter of our
Father three daughters
you got another five-year window here
there then they're eventually gonna love
you but you're gonna be I'll take the
five years you're saying that the latter
is true I'll take that okay
oh yeah once you know they got to be 20
in a little older they were delight to
be around it was it was that window of
around 12 13 to around 19 and I went who
are you
so I'm looking forward to that but I'm
also not looking forward to my younger
who's still my little angels and you
know wants to be around and gets up with
me in those places and does stuff you
know I don't want that to shift into
what one of the other with me well
that's inevitable - hey great to catch
up with you as always tell Berg we set a
low and it's mild 22 hits theaters this
Friday with Mark Wahlberg actually gave
me a little bit of peaceful thank you
Mark it's Mark Wahlberg for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel two
three
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
[Music]